les débris fumants encore dans cette
halle marchande de tir nif cette nuit la
russie a bombardé plusieurs bâtiments
civils de cette ville du nord de
l'ukraine malgré des engagements pris la
veille lors des pourparlers de paix à
istanbul moscou avait pourtant annoncé
réduire ses activités militaires pour
rétablir la confiance entre les deux
camps la ville et sa région sont
pilonnée sans relâche depuis le début de
la guerre à ce match n'a pu aussi
l'ennemi a démontré sa soi-disant baisse
d'activité dans la région de tchernihiv
en frappant la ville denis chine
notamment par des frappes aériennes
ils ont aussi fait feu sur la ville de
tchernihiv toute la nuit venue sur appui
aux premiers jeux neo idem dans la
région de kiev aucun signe de retrait
visible des forces russes les sirènes
sont en permanence ces dernières 24
heures des quartiers résidentiels ont
été frappés à plusieurs reprises
haïr pin dans la banlieue ouest de kiev
les autorités ukrainiennes affirment
avoir libéré la ville de l'ennemi il ya
deux jours mais les explosions elles
n'ont pas cessé ses habitants viennent
d'être évacués il se terrait depuis plus
de quatre semaines pris au piège au
milieu des combats jeu les bleus on est
dire pin et on est resté là depuis le
début des frappes jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
se cachait dans la cave d'une maison en
face de chez nous puis un obus est tombé
sur la maison elle a brûlé il n'y a que
la cave qui restait
sur le front est l'armée ukrainienne
résistent elles affirment avoir repris
le contrôle d'une autoroute stratégique
menant à kharkiv la deuxième ville du
pays dans le sud-est la ville portuaire
de marioupol elle est toujours assiégé
un bâtiment du comité international de
la croix rouge a été la cible de
bombardements russes ce mercredi